ننتقل الى غزه حيث نشاهد اثار غاره جديده
معنا من هناك وائل الدحدوح ليضعنا في
تفاصيل هذه الغاره وائل
من الواضح ان الطائرات الاسرائيليه
الحربيه عادت الى تنفيذ الغارات
الاسرائيليه وهذه واحده من الغارات التي
استهدفت ذات المكان الذي كان قد استهدف
خلال مقابله سابقه وتحدثنا عنه في حينها
وهو هي واحده من الغارات ليست من الغارات
الشديده
والفتاكه كما يقولون ولكن هي غاره
اسرائيليه واضح بانها بقنبله صغيره ليست
كبيره
بالمقارنه مع ما كنا نشاهده في في قصف
مناطق مختلفه في مرات سابقه في اماكن
متعدده ايضا لكن هذا يشي بان الغارات
الاسرائيليه مستمره
وانها لم تتوقف على الرغم من ان الدقائق
الماضيه يعني على على مدار نحو 10دقائق
على الاقل لم نلحظ اطلاق صواريخ من قطاع
غزه وكذلك لم نلاحظ نشاطا للطائرات
الاسرائيليه من قبيل تنفيذ غارات
اسرائيليه على الاقل في هذه المنطقه من من
قطاع غزه لكن في مناطق اخرى على سبيل
المثال قباله منطقه رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه
المعلومات الان ترد عن استهداف من قبل
الطائرات الاسرائيليه لمجموعه من
المواطنين في منطقه رفح اقصى جنوب قطاع
غزه والحديث يدور عن ثلاثه اصابات على
الاقل واحده منهم حرجه جدا وهناك حديث عن
وجود شهيد في بينها هذه الاصابات الثلاث
لكن ننتظر المصادر الطبيه لتاكيد هذا
الامر حتى تكون المعلومات موثقه ومؤكده
وبالتالي هذه ضمن سلسله الغارات التي لم
تتوقف بشكل كامل لكنها كانت لاحظنا انها
اصبح بوتيره اقل مما كانت عليه قبيل هذه
الرشقات من الصواريخ او حتى خلال هذه
الرشقات الصاروخيه التي بلغت ذروتها وعادت
هي الاخرى لتتراجع من حيث الاعداد
والنوعيه ايضا وبالتالي هي ما تشبه الفتره
الانتقاليه ربما دقائق انتقاليه ربما تسمح
لصناع القرار في الجانبين
لالتقاط الانفاس للتحليل والتوقع وربما
جمع المعلومات ايضا ومعرفه ما يمكن ان
يحدث من تطورات وبالتالي التعامل بالمثل
من قبيل اذا ما كانت هناك غارات قويه
شديده كثيره غزيره العدد تستهدف مناطق
اكثر مناطق يمكن ان تكون تشكل خطوطا حمر
بالنسبه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه بالتالي يتم
الرد عليها بانواع مختلفه باعداد مختلفه
من الصواريخ وهكذا العكس بالعكس ايضا
فبالتالي يعني هي موجه التصعيد ما تزال
مستمره الان عدنا الى
عدنا الى استماع الى الاستماع الى طائرات
الطائرات الحربيه وواضح بانها نفذت غاره
ولكن بعيده نسبيا في المنطقه الوسطى من
قطاع غزه